in gaza city
this is what israel's retaliation looks
like
a direct hit on the al-sharook tower
it's not yet clear if anyone was inside
the office block
but it is clear that for another day
gaza is crumbling
at hospitals the length of the strip
ambulances shuttle the injured for
treatment
the israelis insist that they are only
targeting terrorists
that civilian deaths are regrettable
among the rubble majeed al-yasri tells
us how israeli intelligence called his
son
to say their home in a block was about
to be hit and that they should leave
[Music]
the beauty hikes up a little bit
as he explains the sound of another
attack
his story is an illustration certainly
of an attempt by israel to limit the
casualties
but then in this tiny enclave there
isn't anywhere really safe to be
and their homes of course have gone
[Music]
they're left to retrieve what they can
this israel says is the objective video
from the military showing a strike which
they say
killed the right-hand man of hamas's top
military commander
hamas fired hundreds of rockets back and
suggested all options were there
mutual ceasefire or keep going
if they want to escalate the resistance
is ready if they want to stop
the resistance is ready they want to
move their hand out of jerusalem
the resistance is ready this is the
message that we delivered
to all the sides and to whoever is
involved
but miles to the north this renewed
conflict and the history behind it has
spawned something else
this is batiyam near tel aviv israeli
jews attacking arabs
in cities across the country there are
riots between the two sides
between tel aviv and jerusalem the arab
community were protecting the mosque
into the evening
we spent the afternoon in the town and
we saw the rubble from the clashes of
the previous night
when jews said arabs attacked them the
point is this
isn't the palestinian west bank this is
a city in the very heart of israel a
place where israeli jews
and palestinian citizens of israel had
been living
alongside each other now they're
fighting
it represents a dangerous change
[Music]
this man told me it was the jews who
provoked the attack
but up the road in a nationalist israeli
demonstration
a different story arab hoodlums with
face masks
ran around the city lighting cars on
fire
lighting buildings on fire synagogues on
for prime minister benjamin netanyahu
this represents a huge challenge
that some say he stoked
we are continuing our efforts to stop
the anarchy and restore governance to
the cities of israel
with an iron fist if needed with all
forces needed
and all authorities required
rockets from gaza again fell on southern
israeli cities tonight
and the israelis retaliated once more
and behind all this a land so divided
for so long
feels right now extremely tense mark
stone sky news in israel